- Welcome back y'all.
Before we say goodbye,
I have one more sweet
story from the internet.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
- So get ready for your
heart to absolutely melt.
This is sweet y'all.
A Virginia mom discovered a treasure trove
of notes her husband writes
to their daughters each day
when he packs their lunches.
That's a lot.
Even more sweet, the girls saved the notes
and the mom lined them all up
and they say things like
"You make us so proud",
"I love being your dad",
and they say "Even though
Valentine's Day is over,
you will always be my Valentine."
It's so cute.
Let's get these amazing
parents in here everybody.
Say hello to Sabrina
and her husband Jordan.
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] What's up y'all?
- How's it going?
- [Kelly] Oh my
- (indistinct) Kelly
- [Kelly] Gosh, I'm
gonna get to you, Jordan.
You're so sweet.
But Sabrina, did you know
- [Jordan] (laughing)
- that he wrote these?
- I knew that he wrote them
but I didn't know what he was writing
or I didn't know that they
were keeping them every day.
So, when I discovered
literally hundreds of notes,
I was just instantly in tears
when I was reading them.
They were just so sweet.
He was saying how proud he is,
how he loves being their
dad, and it just literally,
I couldn't stop crying reading them.
We've been married eight years
and seeing this side of
him is just my favorite.
And the love and support that
he gives our daughters just
you know, makes me just so happy.
We have three daughters and
the fact that they get that
from him just means so much.
- That's so great, Jordan.
You're setting the bar for
the possible men or women,
like whoever they end up with,
you're setting the bar
for what love looks like.
It's so amazing.
So, were you surprised
that they saved them?
- I was very surprised.
So, I had assumed, like most
kids typically will, would
that it would get crumbled
up and thrown into the bottom
of their lunch pail or they'd
be thrown out at lunch time
or I didn't even know
if they were honestly
be reading them half the
time throughout the day,
in case it was kind of too
cool for school kind of thing.
So, when I started doing this,
I mainly did it
just simply to kind of give
them words of encouragement,
a loving encouragement throughout the day.
Just kind, positive affirmations,
letting them know I missed them.
Anything that would be kind of a, you know
memorable for them throughout the day
that kind of get them through it.
But I absolutely love being a girl dad.
It means a lot to me.
I like being able to shape these girls
and let them know that, you
know, men can be both, you know
strong and tough, but also
sensitive and loving as well too.
So,
- Yeah.
- [Jordan] Anything that
if, something as small
as this can make a big lasting
impact for them, then I'm
I'm happy its gotten this far,
I'm happy that they kept all the notes
so they can hopefully look
back on them when they're older
and really appreciate it even more too.
- Oh my gosh, (crowd cheering)
you are such a rad dad.
That is so women everywhere losing it.
Thank you so much Sabrina.
Your job well done finding an awesome guy.
And Jordan, thank you so much.
It's literally, you're setting the bar,
you know for your kids
to know what a relationship
looks like and love looks like.
And that's so important.
Thank you so much.
I'm liking y'all's post right now, right?
(crowd cheering) (bell ring)
And that's not all you two.
Our season long partner
Pilot, pen makers of Frixion,
the go-to race erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate amazing
parents just like y'all.
So, they're gonna give you
$1,000, how's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Wow.
- Thanks.
- Thank you. Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Thank you guys.
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Alyssa Milano, Macklemore and Scott.
And y'all have a great day
and if it's not, well, try and change it.